so we are off to do some family fun
adventures before jen and i head back to
california and i bought this hat online
and it looked really cool on the girl
online but i don't know if it looks as
good on
me
i think i might look like i have a
highlighter on my head but i like it
i think it's really working with the
outfit here we've got a nice skull camo
sweater
uh a handmade scarf from my aunt
everyone is so crafty like i can make
stuff i can't i can make videos but yeah
hmm
not sure we'll see what the sisters
think about it
[Music]
are you are you saying that because you
don't like my hat
do you like my hat no you don't like my
hat i'm saying yes i don't like your hat
so no i do not like it hello i thought
it was quite nice jen this is almost
exactly what we did last year came to
the palace although we won't see cj and
steve here
but steve didn't come home this year but
we we have to go to the cj later he's
got to be in the vlog so we're here yeah
yeah yeah
cj can you play some video games it's a
good idea all nighter jess we could we
could we could
you i don't know if i want to though
i'm not filming so we're at cabela's
grandma's here where'd grandma go holy
crap like this looks like my closet
graham that looks like my closet
it's nice
it's a little soft but i wish it could
be softer
i think it's probably used for actually
going outside and hunting not just hey
you could just wear it around
look at this look at this breakfast
look at this look at this
is santa it's not soft
yeah it's for like
practicality
i'm gonna wear this like around la
like hi i'm here
hello hello look at this
you found me found you look i wanted to
go this goes really well with the camo
color these look so nice jen it's like a
digital camo
digital sand camo
underwear
gosh i am in a heavenly
state of
camo confusion
i think
there might be something wrong here
why is his arm so long
because it fell off
but the other one's really long
really
they busted both fell off
[Music]
those of you don't know what we're doing
uh in far cry you need to collect the
skins of animals so that's essentially
what we're doing skunk
river on earth we're now enduring real
life far cry i would slice up all these
animals and
craft myself a new loot bag
he'd get this
i miss it being called the rucksack
[Music]
i feel like we're in that casino in
vegas
the palazzo oh my gosh
those pops are relentless
i haven't got attacked by an alligator
yet
other alligators i attacked by something
yeah i did they killed me really i
wasn't expecting it
it was like
uh-oh
yeah
i did i was a good girl and didn't buy
anything here he said daddy got a
present no i got this for me
oh this is for you break let's just try
it
oh
boy
i feel like we always get into these
predicaments
looks like it fit
i hope so if nothing else we could unbox
it no i think it's good you know you
just
can't see each other but it's in hey
graham
see you over there
we just went to sephora and we're now in
a bookstore getting some coffee and i
was really excited because i saw these
they're it's called obsessive compulsive
cosmetics they're 100 vegan and cruelty
free and it's a really nice pink color
so i'm going to try it and see see what
happens no
[Music]
all right
oh my god
i don't think this works as advertised
oh my gosh
[Music]
we should never use that again
you got something too let me just figure
out what to do with my face now
scrub it
i had to wipe the pig off my face
i'm really excited we're sitting in a
bookstore and one day next year
i'm gonna have a book here and this one
no i'm in a bookstore
i'm pretty pumped about it man
i gotta get right so we're on our way to
see some christmas lights i think we
probably saw them last year it was the
start of vlogmas that i actually didn't
do but this year i promise i will do
vlogmas uh to the best of my abilities
so let's see some christmas lights
[Music]
good morning
travel log 5 a.m
heading back to california
i haven't really packed we're supposed
to be at the airport
really soon the sun is not out yet
it's oh god it's cold well we're at the
airport here in pittsburgh and i might
have uh dipped into
some candy a little early 6 55am
ready to go home so we're in phoenix
getting a snack
he just said the same thing
i'm really really exhausted
and it's raining in l.a oh my gosh get
out of here
the same thing i have nothing else to
say i have cramps really bad
slightly
ravenous for food so i didn't realize
that this was a large this is this is
big this is yeah this is look at this
this is
massive coffee but i got a small geez i
should have
oh my god i can't even carry it
we finally landed in lax jenna's now
leaving me
i'll see you like maybe we're gonna have
to get our bags first i'm sure i'll see
you in like a day or two i'll probably
see you tomorrow or listen it's pretty
free tomorrow
maybe we can play like video games on
the internet but not actually hang out
you see my eyebrow it's like um this is
when i'm like
so it's like
you say something shady and i say huh
remember when mine was stuck like that
home wait what i got them done and it
was like i was like oh yeah
i need to get them done and maybe we can
go do that on tuesday
okay because they're not open on monday
i can't wait to get my life back in
order i'm really pumped about it happy
vlogmas i'm not sure what day this is
because i've got some vlogs that needed
to be posted so they're a little bit out
of order either way i love you guys i'll
see you uh probably see you after this
so i'm probably going to film the rest
of today unless i don't then this is the
end of this
huh
when somebody says something you don't
like you say
huh
thank you
[Music]